Hey how's it going my name is since for
get to work is here yes oh yeah I know
it some more the others in your deals he
called get to work say it's time for the
anacondas to get to work this is Sims 4
it's this what I was doing last time
where's my family
oh that's him Travis Scott who is Travis
Scott excuse me Travis Scott what am i
doing in this little hole where did I go
what happened okay let's get rid of
Travis Scott cuz I don't like him minute
his attitude go in there take it I take
a bath Travis okay
now Travis Scott do me a favor go in
there and take a bubble bath of death or
I will destroy you take a bubble bath I
don't care take a bubble bath there's a
toilet right there you [ __ ] idiot
just pee in the bath like a normal
person
ha ha your move
peds I mean Travis Scott your move
Travis scared Oh hoots be like daddy yes
you doing that Travis Scott but you wish
you weren't wearing a v-neck now Travis
Scott yes I cut you like a Pokemon okay
you're moving Travis Scott
I think it's time for pills to get out
there you know in the real world stop
dating a ghost start dating IRL whatever
diet whatever the hell that means join a
career click to find a job for field
just doesn't want to do it does it has
no aspirations in life the most
realistic game of all time there there
it is okay what should we select for
pudding
detective pity detective pits of curse
how you doing there Travis Scott Travis
Scott was a happy man in a v-neck now
Travis Scott is a sad man behind a
toilet
it's my gnome dead Jesus Christ did my
gnome die I didn't know gnomes could die
why why must all gnomes die helix looks
great look at me look at me so handsome
so muscular so ready to be a cop ah
there it is Travis Scott
oh no the toilet died oh no Travis Scott
became a toilet that is awesome
welcome to the police it's time to start
fighting crap hey look at me sexy sexy
sexy damn cat eyes hello hello are those
pillows in there and Jesus Christ it's
not okay I'm not at the workspace Puetz
not at the workspace maybe we can meet a
new new person to bring home and murder
I mean no I'm a cop I can't do that jail
what I better set them free let's
release Jason Pendleton cuz I'm a guy
I'm new at the job Jason don't worry
about it
don't worry about it Jason you're free
have fun
alright let's take a mug shot Jason
vacation
look smile for the camera what am i
doing at Facebook
good job here's some proud of you that
is definitely not your work website
let's offer her a rose
oh she join thanks hello hello damn it
I'm getting cock-blocked by a ghost oh I
didn't do what I was supposed to do damn
it great first day I didn't do anything
I flirted with my boss no so that's a
win Felix did a terrible job today crime
will surely flourish due to such sniglet
neglige [ __ ] it okay let's make sure we
actually do with the right stuff this
time go on Patrol yes I discovered a
clue
the suspect is wearing shorts
interesting okay we're in patrol baby oh
yeah yeah better take this seriously I
take my job very seriously
why is deaf out here why is deaf
shopping for bikinis and sports surprise
deaf deaf you say you my love hello
we're taking a selfie together probably
shouldn't save that it cuz I'm probably
get fired if someone sees it that lady
talking to his chair I think she knows
we're watching her goddamn woodwork end
soon and I'd do anything today either
dabit training is complete and it's time
to run your own case they'd love to
gather evidence uncover clues track down
your suspect get to confess their crimes
that's awesome okay let's do that
alright let's get our kit case
assignment okay here we go I think this
is Heisenberg's house what am i doing
out in the desert
sorry a drug cartel here if we just have
a fight why would they walking like you
put their pants on fighting criminals
yeah that's better
ask [ __ ] you up we're going away to
fight I think Felix did a good job today
Wow look how much money I made damn I'm
a rich lam Tim you nappy indeed all
right back to day number three odd job
today is the day where we finally have a
mental breakdown and release everyone
you're free
don't worry but I'm doing my job you're
free
we're going outside with the inmates
okay
Darien where are you going Darien still
alive this is a marriage look how old
Cheers this tits are nearly at the floor
you have a reason to live now Pierce and
any counters back friends do you
remember oh my god it was forever ago oh
my god we have totally hitting it off
yes
[Music]
yes okay let's end it what wins Sweden
like to call some right on Titan alright
friends let's leave these two lovebirds
alone what do you say you leave a like
if you enjoyed this episode and let me
know what you thought about I don't know
whatever
leave a comment about gnomes and how
they are the deaf to all mankind
now zebras in the next one as always
they was watching stay awesome first oh
he voluntarily jumped in in my pool oh
you made a big mistake today buddy
you're in my domain yeah don't you dare
teleport out yes i trapped you of that